- Home for me, first of
all, is a peace of mind,
where you come home
and you're always safe.
That's what home means to me,
especially for my children.
Before I moved into this
home six months ago,
I was livin' in the shelter.
To get my own home, it
was just breathtaking.
But there was nothin' in it.
(soft music)
- I'm Kristen Suhy and I'm
a designer at Humble Design.
Everything in this warehouse
you see is donated.
We work with homeless and
domestic abuse shelters
with families that are moving
out of those shelters and into homes.
And a lot of times they have nothing
but the clothes on their back.
That's where we step in
and we provide the furniture for them,
but then we also go back and decorate
and provide like those little details
that make your house a home
and makes it your home.
Without our help, about 46%
of families coming out of
the shelter go right back in.
With our help, that statistic
goes down to one percent.
- I'm a direct care worker
and I work with older elder people.
Before I lived in the shelter
the boyfriend that I was living with
was emotionally and
physically abusive to me.
One day I woke up and I just said
I wasn't takin' that anymore.
- Today we met with Danyle
and we just talked with her a little bit,
found out about her back story.
It sounds like she has
come out of the shelter
and now has been in a house
with basically no furniture.
She has a few pieces but no
beds, no chairs, no table.
So we talked with her a little bit
about what she wants in her home.
We went to the home and
we took measurements,
and just walked through each room.
About, a bigger table?
- What dinner looks at my house now,
we all sit together but
we sit on the floor.
The priorities was to have
silverware, bowls and spoons,
stuff, things for us to eat out of.
And bedding to put on the floor for us
'cause we didn't have beds.
- When I first started
here, I didn't realize
that people were living this way.
When you walk into a home
that is completely empty
and families are living there
and have lived there for
months, it's shocking,
because you don't think of it.
But on that Friday when we reveal a house,
I just love the energy from our volunteers
to the families that are
getting these, you know, new homes, really.
I just, I can't get enough of that feeling
and that's why I have
stayed here for so long.
- I know my kids are gonna be amazed
'cause I haven't really
told them what's goin' on,
I just told them they
was gettin' some beds.
So they don't even know
that the whole house
is gonna be done.
So I know they're gonna
be astounded, happy.
It just makes me very happy.
Oh,
wow.
- Ooh.
(laughing)
- Oh my God!
- It's like a magazine.
Went from zero to a miracle. (laughing)
I love y'all for this,
I mean, this is amazing.
This is just happiness to me,
to be able to walk into a home
and have your friends and family there
and you're able to just
show them comfort and joy.
That means a lot to me.
And I hope that one day I can give back,
just what was given to me.
(upbeat music)